a FIFA had little option but to stage
the Qatar World Cup in winter well
January and February were ruled out to
avoid clashing with the 2022 Winter
Olympics two of the bidding countries
Kazakhstan and China have already
pledged to hold the games in February
and April is also out because the
fasting month of Ramadan begins on the
second and after that it'll simply just
be too hot from May to September the
conditions will be unbearable for both
the players and the fans so with two
consecutive months needed November and
December have been identified as the
only feasible option and Athene was
explaining that would mean that the
Premier League season would have to
start a month earlier in July and UEFA
competitions would also have to be
brought forward as well so that players
could be released from their respective
clubs in October to prepare for the
tournament UFO which preferred a January
to a February competition has accepted
that decision and it's expected to be
approved next month